he's Andre Ingram the Lakers 32 year old
rookie star and quite a debut it took
him 10 years to become an overnight
sensation
Andre thanks for joining us
congratulations how do you explain this
why did it take 10 years to become an
overnight sensation you know I have no
idea the timing of it all is quite the
story itself but I mean maybe it was the
perfect time and who knows you just go
about your business and try to do what
you believe is right what you're
supposed to do and you know hopefully
you feel the state comes whether it's
ten years down the line or not but for
all I know it's perfect time and day and
I have no idea when when's the last time
where you said it's just not going to
happen you you talked to your wife and
just say look it's just now I'm not
gonna get called up yeah you know there
was a midway point in that in that 10
year span where that probably happened
you know you're four or five years into
the d-league and you know at the feeling
close for so long and especially doing
that first part kind of passing up some
opportunities abroad especially in my
early years and you know because you
felt close and so when it didn't happen
again and again they were on that
midpoint you started to say well man
maybe we started making the wrong
decisions here and so at that point the
discouragement probably hit the most but
then men after stepping away from it for
a while and just kind of appreciating
what you get to do anyway and realize
that you are playing and you know that
to be encouraged still that hey you are
closer I know then feel like it you
can't see and you haven't heard anything
but you are close and then the field as
good as I did I just decided hey man
we're just gonna go see what then it's
gonna be whether you make it or not what
was that first jumper like Travis wears
all throughout the season the Yahoo Pass
me the ball but I you can see it form in
and you know happens in every game and
you can you know kind of see the ball
swing and then defenders moving and you
kind of know that open shot is coming to
you to be honest with you all I knew is
that
going to shoot it that's really all I
knew I love that oh and yeah you know
guys they've been telling me hey when
you get the ball as soon as you touch it
just shoot it wherever you're at you
know not knowing when you get the ball
you probably be 50 feet out with
somebody on you you're not gonna shoot
that one but this one I can see Foreman
and so yeah all I knew was I going to
shoot it I didn't know we could go in
and not obviously when it went in you
know hallelujah did you get hazed yet
since you're a rookie you know what you
know Jenna fries in the locker room II
was uh if there's a weight I mean do we
consider you're working and so yeah I
thought some hazing was about to happen
at that point but they they took it easy
on me they they didn't make me do much
at all we had enough rookies on the team
anyway so I got off on the rocky duty
for at least of two nights yeah Andre
you might be more of a rookie than Ben
Simmons yeah that's true no I you know
in my mind I'm every bit of the rookie
you mean the whole experience is new for
me for guys to see me in a different
light you know I mean I've had guys on
the team comment me hey man you don't
care yourself as a rookie in this league
at all you know no matter where you play
you kind of look like you belong and fit
out there so you know I got a comment
from a lot of guys and a lot of
teammates expressing you know just the
demeanor part of it that they were
pretty impressed that meant something to
hear that give us give the audience an
idea of the the cities that you go to in
the G League the stops that you had when
you're when you're playing on the road
what are the cities you're playing in
mm-hm
yeah I mean they're not cities you go to
on vacation you know you got a you know
Sioux Falls and in Erie Pennsylvania and
you know just just a lot of cities and
within these states that you know you
probably just drive by our pass by you
know obviously playing with the LA
defenders and even before that I began
my year with the Utah flash we would
play down in Orem Utah LA was probably
the best trip out of all of them when I
even used to play against these guys I
mean it was our favorite trip of all but
the other cities you go to they're not
known places you probably haven't
visited
them unless you had d-league business to
go to orgy leases offenses yeah I mean
yeah it's but at the same time it's
beneficial for those d-league teams and
d-league teams because you know that
that community that you're in they are
all for you
so I played in some great atmospheres in
the d-league actually it's just not uh
you know cities that you've probably
been through get your first paycheck yet
not yet
patiently waiting I think I can wait for
this one
what about per diem you know just just
the difference of G League - you get to
the Lakers and meal money and you know
people pick it up your back and like
give us the difference between the two
yeah so the the second of the bags and
you know taking your gear and stuff to
the you know arena for the game that
part I have experienced the the civilian
part not so much cos obviously I last
two home games where I mean they were at
home so okay okay yeah didn't experience
for them yet but yeah I mean it is a bit
different you know in dealey you all
your stuff comes with you it is on your
suitcases knowing your carry-on when you
go to the airport but yeah this time you
know all of my things were there at the
locker room for me before I got there so
that was a bit of a different feel and
how did it feel when did you did you
shoot against Jimmer Fredette were you a
three-point shooting contest in the G
League that's correct the one in Toronto
it was a Jimmer Fredette and I in the
finals of that three-point contest and
you won did did that give you any
confidence or did you expect to win you
know what I don't know the expectation
part of it but I really wanted to win
like I really wanted this one for
whatever reason I was shooting it
excellently that year I think even over
50 at that point of the season and yeah
I really wanted that one it's funny my
you know wife's family all big fans of
you know Jimmer for that my wife went to
school in Utah so my family or her
family was very you know well-known to
him and so yeah it meant a lot to have
that victory and the shooters as well as
I did in that car
it was it was unbelievable I I wanted to
win I didn't expect that shoot like that
I know that a lot of times we'll focus
in on the athlete who you know has this
story and everything that happens for
him but without your wife and the
sacrifices that she had and you both
make sacrifices but you know that says I
think you took off an entire year so you
could take care of your daughter and
then your wife could go finish her
college degree is that right yeah that
was the first season that uh that I took
time off yeah our first daughter was
born and she really needed to finish up
schooling so I mean we just we just
switched her schools and classes were in
the morning and so I watched Malia my
oldest daughter then and Men in Tights I
would work and you know she would watch
Malia during the night I mean we just we
worked together and you know once she
finished her when she completed you know
her classes and what-have-you I was able
to that was my first year actually with
the LA G League team to end that season
is at the very end of it but yeah I mean
we her sacrifices as you say it's
probably a lot bigger than mine
especially this entire G League season
which was the first she was without me
and I had both of our kids were now in
school so I mean was it was a rough
season in that respect for her but to
her credit dad I mean she was all for it
I mean she encouraged it you know she's
like we don't have to you know live with
you this year let's get the girls
straighten we'll see you next year so I
got to see him periodically throughout
the year East Coast trips and what have
you so it worked out fine and you
studied physics at American I did how
come my my physics well I actually went
to my high school it was specially
Center for engineering and so I wanted
to go on the engineering field
particularly Electrical something along
those lines and but I was American
didn't offer that I went on a basketball
scholarship I figured physics was you
know in that realm one of the closest
things looking back I probably should've
done math specifically because the math
of physics I got pretty well the science
of it still puzzles me to this day as it
would anyone else so
but yeah that was a just major in
physics and I was glad I did it was
challenging I mean at that point taught
me a lot about balance in your time and
things like that because there was no
shortcuts in this I really had to do the
work I really had to commit to
basketball as well so I mean even
something that early and taking
something that challenging and playing
college ball you know helped me with
time management things and sacrifice and
what-have-you
he's Andre Ingram the Lakers 32 year old
rookie guard do you get to keep the
jersey that back for you go ahead and
put that Jersey in there and everything
you want awesome so then there is
nothing left in that locker we got a
nickname for you since you you did tutor
kids in math right yep I think you
should be known as the tutor like you
scored people like you teach people you
reach I teach you're the tutor well
that's the first one I've heard yeah and
a guard Andre the tutor Ingram
hey good luck it's a great story more
importantly great stuff with your family
pretty pretty cool things there and
hopefully you get an opportunity to
stick next year yes sir then thank you
man I appreciate it thank you
Andre the tutor Ingram four more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
you